upcoming guests when the show comes back
on October 28th you have kaley cuoco who
we love she's in the CBS yes family yeah
I know I am because I'm here so how is
having her on the show she's great it's
always interesting having someone that
you don't know on the show because you
never know how they're gonna be or I
naturally assume they're going to think
my show is stupid and beneath them so
I'm prepared for that and usually I'm
disappointed and they actually have a
really great time so she was really
wonderful and stayed there for a long
time and I think when the second guest
gets out there in in our show the second
guest is always a comedian playing a
character she just was having a ball and
really laughing and our second guest Kay
pearl and made her laugh a lot so it was
really fun to see we actually have a
little preview of the episode with
Kaylee and Karen selling her Karen water
mm-hm this is comedian Kay pearl and
playing Karen an insane person who's
selling water I'm here today let's talk
about Karen water oh okay new products
that I'm so excited about people are
writing in they're calling in they're
talking to their families and their
pastors about it it's been reported that
within the first 30 days of drinking
Karen water people either meet someone
or start a franchise okay
I've had infertile women go not anymore
do you think they're just pointing at
the water say not anymore I'm not gonna
drink this anymore because it's like
infertility you know I've met with women
who go I'm infertile what do I do and I
go here's what you do sweetheart three
weeks later they go I'm three weeks
pregnant three weeks pregnant are you
legally allowed to say that I mean
that's a big statement well when you've
had women that have given birth and you
catch the baby and you go oh my god it's
a Karen water baby I can tell by the
weight and the softness of the skin they
almost so bad your hands is dangerous
I've actually should put something on
here babies become dangerously soft when
concede yeah its water though I mean
you're kind of not to be offensive but
water is water let me just do it
I hear that how is your water different
from other water Karen water is
different because it's number one
molecule free okay number two publicly
bless I bless every single bottle
publicly in the town square I gather up
all hot the governor I'll have the mayor
he'll who cares
and number three every bottle of Karen
has a strand of my hair in it and that's
actually certified of your hair really
my hair I have some to spare yeah no you
have a wild mane but I don't know that I
want to be drinking water with hair in
it it's actually it's seasons it gently
and also it's a way to ensure that I'm
with you that as you're drinking that
you go
Karen's really here and she cares and
physically I am with you that's a cliff
god that was excellent
oh boy I I work on the show and
sometimes I watch it now I don't know
how they do they must be high or
something
you